this summer
you do as I say Drake Jr and we'll never
speak of this again
[Applause]
[Music]
Sonia Eddie star of General Hospital has
died she was 55 years old
one minute I'm being informed that you
have checked out a GH against doctor
orders next minute you're calling me
telling me that your associate is
waiting for me downstairs to drive me
here where am I anyway and what the hell
is going on
the news of Sonia's death was confirmed
to ET on Tuesday by the General Hospital
Family executive producer Frank
Valentini remembered the actress in part
quote the lights in the hub of the
nurses station will now be a little
dimmer but her spirit and light will
live on in both the show and on our set
on behalf of the entire GH cast and crew
we send our deepest sympathy to her
family friends and fans she will be very
missed Sonia's friend and fellow actress
Octavia Spencer first broke the news and
included this tribute writing quote my
friend Sonia Eddie passed away last
night the world lost another creative
Angel her Legions of General Hospital
fans will miss her my thoughts and
prayers are with her loved ones friends
and fans at this time a cause of death
has not yet been revealed
precious stable blood loss wasn't severe
he's a very lucky man the bullet went
clean through
Sonia was one of the longest running
cast members on General Hospital
starring in more than 500 episodes
you can't let anything stop you
not even this
you know what everybody is seems to be
extremely excited so I'm I'm pleased the
actress joined the GH crew in 2006 as
Epiphany the new head nurse hello
this is a Epiphany Johnson established
with it
people take theirselves serious I mean
is there a time when they come here and
they actually think you really are a
nurse I have been called Epiphany
nobody's asked me to take their pulse
yet but it has happened
do you get ever get a little edgy like
oh go out you know do they ever hug a
little too long
um I have been kissed on the mouth
didn't even see her coming she was
little now you got to be short to be
shorter than me and she came in up under
my arm and pow I was like whoa okay then
aside from the soap Sonia appeared in
many other beloved series getting her
start on The Drew Carey Show
we're there and other shows like Glee
castle and Seinfeld are you the ones
leaving those muffin pieces behind our
shelter you've been enjoying them
they're just stops
well they're they're perfectly edible oh
so you just assumed that the homeless
will eat them they'll eat anything
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]